[موسيقى]
دع البيان الختامي الصادر عن الاجتماع
الخماسي في شرم الشيخ لبناء الثقه بنى
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين واشار لنا
السلطه الفلسطينيه هي من يطلع بالمهام
الامنيه في المنطقه الف واكد البيان على
عدم المساسب الوضعيه التاريخيه للاماكن
المقدسه في القدس وكانت فصائل فلسطينيه قد
نكدت بالاجتماع ومشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه
فيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي اختلف من
مخرجات في اجتماع مدينه شرم الشيخ عن تلك
التي رشحت عن اجتماع العقبه في ضوء البيان
الصادر عن الاجتماع الخماسي في مصر كيف
ستبدو مواقف مختلف الاطراف المحليه
والاقليميه والدوليه من هذه المخرجات وما
الذي سيضمن تنفيذها بالنظر الى التملص
حكومه نتنياهو من الاتفاقات سابقه الى اين
تتجه الاوضاع في المنطقه على ضوء مخرجات
اجتماع شرم الشيخ بالنظر الى التداخل عده
عوامل من بينها اختلاف المواقف الفلسطينيه
والمعارك الداخليه التي تخوضها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
هو استكمال الاجتماع العقبه الذي عقد بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين في السادس
والعشرين من فبراير شباط الماضي وفيه
استمر البحث برعايه اقليميه ودوليه عن
تهدئه بين الجانبين تعززها الوقائع على
الارض هدف دونه عوامل متداخله زادها
تعقيدا التصعيد المستمر في الضفه والقدس
منذ بدايه هذا العام في مخرجات البيان
الختامي نقاط مهمه واشارات تنتظر الواقع
العملي ليختبر قدرتها على مغادره الورق
الى الواقع الذي يشهد تصعيدا مستمرا خاصه
في القدس والضفه بيان اكد على التزام كل
من اسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه بكل
الاتفاقيات السابقه كما اشارت مخرجاته الى
ان الجانبين الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني اتفقا
على استهداف اليه للحد من العنف والتحريض
واتخاذ ما يلزم لفتح افاق سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اناقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي امين عمل مبادرة
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن نيوجيرسي يا سيد
المبعوث الخاص السابق لرئيس ملكه
الشرق اوسط مرحبا بكم دكتور مصطفى
ربما هي لهجه مغايره في هذا البيان عن
بيان العقبه هل يمكن البناء عليها
اطلاقا له ولا انا لا ارى شيئا كثيرا
مغايرا في الواقع لانه الاتفاق هو اتفاق
امني فقط يتعلق بالقضايا الامنيه فقط لا
يوجد ذكر لجوهر الامر وهي القضايا
السياسيه وعلى راسها وجود واستمرار
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ونظام الابرتايد
العنصري والمجازر التي ترتكب ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني وانا استغرب جدا ان تعود السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي توافق على صيغه تقول الحد
من
انشاء مناقشه وحدات استيطانيه جديده
لاربعه شهور يعني 13 مستعمره التي اقرت
اسرائيل بنائها مقبوله والعشر الاف وحده
استطانيه التي اقرتها اسرائيل تستمر وكانه
كل شيء تمام هذا شيء غريب الامر الاخر
الحديث عن اليات لوضع حد للعنف والتحريض
والتصريحات
يعني شو هذا الكلام يعني المساواه بين
الطرفين هل هذا يعني انه ستدفع السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى اليات لقمع حريه الراي
والتعبير لدى الشعب الفلسطيني او لوقف
مقاومته هذا كلام غريب ونحن نخشى من ان
هذا الاجتماع يمكن ان يحاول ان يستدرج
الجانب الفلسطيني الى صراع داخليا في
الساحه الفلسطينيه في الوقت الذي نتعرض
فيه جميعا للمجازر والقتل والتنكيل للاسف
الشديد
هو العوده اذا سمحت لي لانه
السلطه تطلع بالمسؤوليه الامنيه في
المنطقه الف بالضفه الغربيه هو ربما يرفع
الحرج عن دخول قوات اسرائيليه لمنطقه الف
ولكن ايضا يضع السلطه امام مواجهه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه صحيح
ولن ينجح ذلك لن ينجح ذلك لانه اولا نحن
نرفض ان تستدرج السلطه الفلسطينيه واي
جانب فلسطيني لصراع داخلي يؤدي ربما الى
اقتتال داخلي هذا اخطر ما يمكن ان يحدث
والامر الثاني انا متاكد ان اسرائيل لن
تسمح بذلك ايضا لن تسمح للسلطه بان تعود
للسيطره المطلقه على مناطق الف
وانتظروا قليلا وستروا ان جيش الاحتلال لن
يتوقف عن اقتحام جنين او نابلس او اي
مدينه فلسطينيه اخرى كما يفعل منذ عام
2002 الامر الاخر المهم انه للاسف الشديد
في الوقت الذي هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الفاشيه العنصريه تواجه عزله داخليه شديده
وانقسام داخليا كبير وتواجه عزله دوليه
متصاعده يعني ياتي هذا الاجتماع كانه
يمنحها طوق النجاه وهذا شيء غريب هذه
الحكومه يجب ان تقاطع لا ان تجري معها
الاجتماعات وان يعود الجميع للتنسيق
الامني وايضا للاتفاقيات البائسه التي قرر
المجلس المركزي التحلل منها وهذا هذا هذا
البيان مناقد لقرارات مجلس المركزي لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه سمعت طبعا راي الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي بمخرجات اجتماع شرم الشيخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المهتمه بهذا
الجانب الجانب الامني بين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلياسيه من خلال شهر رمضان
المبارك
كيف برايك تنظر الى هذه المخرجات
اعتقد ان واسم سوف تنظر الى حقيقه انك
الطرفين التقيا واصدره وثيقه هذا بحد ذاته
في رايها تقدم في الاشهر الماضيه ما كان
احد منا يستطيع ان يتوقع باننا بحلول
نهايه شهر مارس اذار ستكون الامور بهذه
الدرجه بحيث ان الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
يتفقون على اي شيء ما كان ليتفق على ان اي
وقت من النهار نحن فيه الان بسبب استمرار
القتل في كلا الجانبين وجهه نظر واشنطن
تقوم على اساس ان
الفلسطينيين اذا ما ارادوا دولتهم كان
هناك عرض قدم لهم في وقت
سابق قبل هذه المستوطنات وياسر عرفات هل
يريد الفلسطينيين دولتهم ام يريدون ازاله
اسرائيل وغيابها هذا ما تريد واشنطن سماع
جواب له لان الاخير لو كان ان الدوله
الفلسطينيه تمتد من البحر المتوسط الى نهر
الاردن واضح هذا لن يكون مقبولا للولايات
المتحده ولكن لو انها دوله فلسطينيه يمكن
ان تكون امنه حيث
الصواريخ التي انتجت في غزه بعد اعاده
اسرائيل تلك الاراضي لم تحول او لن تنتج
في الدوله الفلسطينيه الجديده وهناك
ضمانات امنيه واشنطن لم تمانع في ذلك ربما
ستقول ببساطه دعوا جانبا ما يحدث مع
عمليات القتل وواشن واوصلت رسال
اذا سمحت انت قلت اذا سمحت لي انت قلت بان
مجرد الاجتماع واصدار وثيقه بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي هو انجاز
هذا اقصى ما تستطيع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحقيقه في هذه المرحله بين
الجانبين
كلا طبعا انا اقول هذه الخطوه الاولى
الحد الاقصى سيكون بصراحه شيء لا يبدو كلا
او اين من الجانبين ان يحققوه او يعمل من
اجلك كهدف وهو حل الدولتان هذا لا يبدو
مقبولا بصراحه لكثير من الاسرائيليين
وخاصه
نتنياهو الذي فقط يتظاهر بهذا الفكر لا
ادري حقيقه اذ كان يرغب في ذلك واعتقد ان
كثيرا من الفلسطينيين لا يريدون ذلكم
يريدون دوله فلسطينيه لا تشمل دوله
اسرائيل هذا يبدو الهدف لواشق وليس
الوثيقه لكن علينا ان نبدا في نقطه ما
وهذه الوثيقه كانت اشاره من نوع ما بان
كلا الطرفان يمكن ان يتحدثاك طرفين
متساويين وبعضهما البعض هذا يمثل تقدم
دكتور مصطفى هي نقطه اذا تمثل تقدم بحسب
الراي الراي سيد ريتشرد الرعايه الامريكيه
المصريه الاردنيه لا يمكن ان تكون ضامنه
لتنفيذ بنود
اجتماع شرم الشيخ بتقديرك
لن تسمح اسرائيل لاحد ان يكون ضامنا ونحن
راينا ما جرى في العقبه جرى تمزيق ما تم
الاتفاق عليه قبل ان يجف الحبر على الورق
الذي كتب فيها ولكن دعني اشير الى نقطه
ذكرها ضيفك الامريكي الذي للاسف يتبنى
بشكل كامل الروايه الاسرائيليه الرئيس
ياسر عرفات لم يرفض عرضا السلام الرئيس
ياسر عرفات في اجتماع كانديفيد رفض ان لا
تكون القدس عاصمه لدوله فلسطين
ورفض ان تكون الدوله الفلسطينيه مقطعه
الاجزاء وان تواصل اسرائيل السيطره على
الاغوار وبالتالي لم يكن هناك عرض بدوله
فلسطينيه مستقله هذا غير صحيح هذا الكلام
وهذا غير مقبول وهذه محاوله لتحميل الضحيه
المسؤوليه عن الجرائب الاسرائيليه كذلك من
غير مقبول القول ان الفلسطينيين طاردوا
اسرائيل بالصواريخ اسرائيل ما زالت تحتل
غزه برا وبحرا وجوا اسرائيل تحاصر غزه برا
وبحرا وجوا اسرائيل هي التي تعتدي في غزه
واهل غزه يدافعون عن انفسهم ولكن الامر
الاخطر والاهم في هذا الاجتماع انه يساوي
بين الطرفين كيف يمكن المساواه بين المحتل
والذي تحت الاحتلال بين الذي يمارس نظام
ابارتايد عنصري والذي يتعرض لنظام ابرتيد
كيف يمكن المساواه امنيا بين الطرفين وطرف
يمتلك جيش هو الخامس في القوه من في
العالم واكبر جيش في العالم في المنطقه
ويعتدي وينفذ المجازر ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
ويساوى بالفلسطينيين شو يعني وقف التحريض
هل هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه هي التي تمارس
التحريض ام الفلسطينيين لا يمكن المساواه
بين الطرفين والخطوره الكبيره في هذا
البيان انه يساوي بين الطرفين ويتحدث فقط
في الامور الامنيه لم تذكر كلمه دوله
فلسطينيه ولا حتى كلمه حل الدولتين التي
يتحدث عنها الامريكان واذا كان الامريكيون
فعلا حريصون على حل الدولتين ويقول في نفس
الوقت ان الاس يدمر حل الدولتين لماذا لا
يضغطوا على اسرائيل وهم الاكثر قدره على
الضغط على اسرائيل لماذا لا يلزم التوسع
الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي طلع هون في قضيه
خطيره جدا ان تقول ممنوع مناقشه وحدات
جديده ل 4 اشهر بس بهمش يكملوا بناء
المستعمرات ال 13 وبهمه يستمر التوسع
الاستيطاني المقر والعشره الاف وحده
استيطانيه هذا اغراق في الضلال وهذا كانه
يعطي تشريعا لاستمرار الاستيطان الولايات
المتحده لو ارادت تستطيع ان تلجم اسرائيل
وتوقف الاستيطان فورا ولكنها لا تريد فعل
ذلك
الولايات المتحده لا تريد ام هي غير قادره
الان مع حكومه مثل حكومه نتنياهو على
اجبار
اليمين المتطرف في هذه الحكومه على وقف
هذه الممارسات كما قال الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي
في الحقيقه
الضغط يتم تطبيقه حاليا ربما لا يتم ذلك
علنا ولكن اعتقد انه عندما يلتقي وزير
الخارجيتنا بكبار المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
وعندما يكون للرئيس بيت المحادثات مع بيبي
نتنياهو يتم ايصال الموقف الامريكي له
بشكل واضح اعتقد ان قرارا اتخذ ربما ليس
عن طريق الاعلام عنه علنا ولكن من خلال
جعل نتنياهو يتخذ قرارات من دون ضغوط
واعتقد ان هذا من الحكمه ان تعطيه المتحده
هامشا من المناوره للوصول الى النتيجه
التي تريد تحقيقها الولايات المتحده لذا
هي ليست مساله عدم الرغبه في فرض ضغوط لان
الضغط يتم فرضه لكننا لن نعرف ذلك لفتره
من الزمن لكن حقيقه ان هذا الاجتماع قد تم
وتم اصدار بيان عنه يدل على انه ايا كانت
ما تفعله الوقت المتحده هو نافع وليس ضارا
دكتور مصطفى اذا عدنا الى الشان الداخلي
الفلسطيني السلطه تقول بان انتقادها
للمشاركه في هكذا اجتماعات
والتنسيق الامني باقل
باقل حدوده ربما هي مزايده لانه بديل
الاجتماعات هو مزيد من من التصعيد ما ردكم
على هذا
انا اسال سؤال بسيط هل من حق شعب تحت
الاحتلال ان يقاوم الاحتلال ام لا اليس
القانون الدولي
ومواثيق الامم المتحده
اليست تقول انه من حق اي شعب تحت الاحتلال
ان يقاوم هذا الاحتلال
الصراع هنا على ماذا يدور شعب تحت
الاحتلال يريد ان يتحرر من الاحتلال
السلطه الفلسطينيه انا برايي بدل ان تذهب
لمقابله حكومه فاشيه عنصريه يجلس فيها
الذي يقول انه يريد ان يغرق الضفه الغربيه
بالمستعمرات والمستعمرين حتى يفقد
الفلسطينيون اي امل في دوله لهم ويقول
امام الفلسطينيين ثلاث خيارات واحد من
ثلاث خيارات اما ان يرحلوا او يستسلم
لنظام الفاشل الاسرائيلي ويخضع له او يموت
هذا اهم ثاني وزير في هذه الحكومه بدل ان
تذهب في هذا الاتجاه المفروض ان تذهب في
اتجاه توحيد الصف الوطني الفلسطيني توحيد
القوى الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كلها نحن لا
نريد ان نتصارع مع بعض وهدفنا ليس مجرد
الانتقاد هدفنا ان نكون في وحده وطنيه
راسخه وان نتفق على استراتيجيه وطنيه
كفاحيه
جرب عفوا عفوا بعد ان جربت السلطه 30 عاما
جربت السلطه سلطه نهج المفاوضات ونهجوسلو
وفشل فشلا ذريعا هذا هو الواقع في هذه في
هذا الجانب على مستوى التحركات الشعبيه
الفلسطينيه نظم المؤتمر الشعبي الفلسطيني
ومنظمات شبابيه وقفه احتجاجيه في مدينه
غزه رفضا لاجتماع شرم الشيخ الامنيه الذي
يبحث التهدئه في الضفه الغربيه الوقفه
طالبت بتصعيد اشكال الاحتجاج كافه وصفه
الاجتماع بانه استكمال للمؤامره على
المقاومه وخيار الشعب ودعت الوقفه في بيان
صدر عنها الى انهاء الانقسام الفلسطيني
والتوحد خلف المقاومه نعم هناك انقسام
فلسطيني واضح ولكن الان ايضا حكومه
نتنياهو تخوض ولاول مره ربما معارك سياسيه
داخليه
ومواجهات في الشارع مع الاسرائيليني الى
اي مدى هذا الهاجس ايضا يلعب دورا في هذا
النوع من الاجتماعات بتقديرك
اعتقد ان كلا الطرفين
عليهم مواجهه الواقع واضح ان هناك
فلسطينيون ليس فقط في غزه والذين يفضلون
ام لا يكون هناك اي اتصال بصفه رسميه بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
لان وجهه النظر الوحيده لديهم مقابله
اسرائيل بقوه السلاح وبالقوه هناك طبعا
اتجاه كبير في اسرائيل والذي يختلف تماما
مع مقاربه نتنياهو ليس فقط في التعامل مع
القتل الذين يلجاون الى الاراضي فلسطينيه
ولكن فيما يتعلق اكثر بخططه في تعديل
النظام القضائي في اسرائيل والذي ولد
احتجاجات لم تر اسرائيل مثلها من قبل اذا
بامكان المرء ان يحاجز بالقول هنا
بان حقيقه ان كلا الكيا الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني
يواجهان هذه
المشاكل الداخليه قد يعيدهما الى جاده
الصواب ليشعرورها بان المسار الحالي لا
يمكن الاستمرار عليه هذا هو
نوع من الاحداث التي قد تعيد الطرفين الى
نوع من المفاوضات ذات المعنى والمغزى لكن
لو ان وجهه النظر الفلسطينيه في خاتمه
المطاف كانت تقوم على اساس ان اسرائيل يجب
ان تقاوم بالسلاح لان الفلسطينيين لا
يمتلكون الحكم الذاتي
فهذا لا يبدو وكانه
مسار قد يؤتي ثماره عندما حصل هذا في
الماضي لا اعتقد ان الشعب الفلسطيني خرج
بحال افضل بعد ان مواجهه الاسرائيلين
بالقوه
ومنذ الانتفاضه الاخيره هناك المزيد من
السلاح في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ولا اعتقد
اننا يجب ان نفكر وهذا السلاح متواجد
بايدي فصائل سيد دكتور مصطفى موقف الفصائل
تقول بان الانتفاضه تزداد قوه ولا يمكن
الاجتماع شرم الشيخ وقفها او الالتفاف
عليها لماذا تشعر الفصائل الفلسطينيه بان
هكذا اجتماعات
لتحيدها وكيف يمكن ان تؤثر هكذا مواقف على
امكانيه تطبيق ما خرج به اجتماع شرم الشيخ
ساجيب على سؤالك ولكن دعني اشير الى
نقطتين اولا بالنسبه لضيفك الامريكي اولا
يعني محاوله تحميل الفلسطينيين المسؤوليه
يعني شيء معبود في للاسف من متحدثين
امريكيين كثيرين يتبنوا الروايه
الاسرائيليه يعني لو من الضحيه لو من الذي
تحت الاحتلال هو لا يتحدث عن العنف
والاجرام الذي تمارس سلطه الاحتلال لا
يتحدث عن عدد القتلى الفلسطينيين والشهداء
الذين استشهدوا على يد جيش الاحتلال حتى
الاداره الامريكيه لا تستطيع ان تفرض على
اسرائيل وقف الاستيطان طب لماذا لا تفتح
القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس اذا فعل صغير
بسيط من هذا النوع لا تتجرا الاداره
الامريكيه على فعله لماذا تستمر في اغلاق
مكتب منظمه التحرير في واشنطن اذا الموضوع
هنا موضوع ضعف وموضوع ضعف الاراده في ان
تقوم بالدور الذي يجب ان تقوم به ولجم
اسرائيل من ناحيه اخرى دعني اقول لك القوه
الفلسطينيه اعط فرصه للمفاوضات اعطت فرصه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه استمر هذا الكلام من
سنه 93 حتى اليوم ماذا كانت النتيجه زاد
عدد المستوطنين من 120 الف الى 750 الف
اصبح المستعمرون المستوطنون قوه مقرره في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليوم وزيران
مستعمران مستوطنان واحد مسؤول عن الامن
الداخلي وواحد مسؤول عن عن كل ما يتعلق
بالضفه الغربيه وعن وزاره الماليه اليوم
نتيجه
المفاوضات ازداد التطرف العنصري
الاسرائيلي ازدادت الهجمات ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني ازدادت اليوم مش بس حكومه
عنصريه حكومه فاشيه شخص مثل يخرج ويقول
انه يفتخر بانه فاشي اذا الشعب الفلسطيني
جرب ذلك الطريق وذلك الطريق فشل واليوم
ليس امامه الا ان يغير ميزان القوى
بالمقاومه والكفاح والصمود والمطالبه بفرض
العقوبات والمقاطعه على حكم الاحتلال شكرا
لكم دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي في رام الله
والسيد ريتشارد غوتستاين في نيوتنسي
الى هنا تنتهي هذا الحلقه من ما وراء
الخبر شكرا لمتابعه الى اللقاء بامر الله
ورعايته
[موسيقى]